so we're going to talk about the seven
symptoms that actually prove you are in
fat-burning okay
and when I say fat-burning I'm talking
about ketosis number one cognitive
affects your memory your focus your
concentration your your attention span
will all improve okay number two your
mood is elevated you're more cheerful
you're less irritable you're less edgy
you have a higher tolerance to stress
you can handle babysitting a lot of kids
in a room for over eight hours in a
daycare center without any problem
number three energy is increase the need
for sleep goes down I require a lot less
sleep now that I'm doing this there
before
no more cravings to carbs sugar candy
cookies and starches that goes away
number five you're not hungry anymore
you can go long periods of time without
food now some of these improvements
might occur initially and as you do it
longer you'll get more of these
improvements so if you're still craving
it means that you're not quite doing it
right or you're not doing it long enough
okay
number six your waist is shrinking okay
it's getting smaller and close our loser
at number seven weight loss now notice
how I put this last and this is very
important okay because most people are
focused on this first but they're
ignoring all the benefits
remember it's get healthy then lose the
weight so part of the get healthy
process is stimulating the anabolic
hormones which I'll explain in a second
that involve taking protein in repairing
tissue in the body so the antibiotic
means a building it's not breaking down
its building back up so what happens
when you do health Aikido and in a
minute fasting especially you're
stimulating more testosterone growth
hormone which then stimulates something
called IGF which is
kind of an extension off growth hormone
and it creates certain effects with a
liver and throughout the body or
actually it's produced by liver but it
works throughout the body and look check
this out insulin is an anabolic hormone
I'll come back to that too and then
glucagon which is also produced in the
pancreas so they work together so what's
happening is a lot of times as you get
older and then you start doing keto you
might not see the huge progress that
some younger person has simply because
you may have a trophy maybe you're going
through menopause and you have a loss of
muscle protein in the legs and the
thighs in the buttocks and it looks just
like that so you get it from a seated
position or you walk up the stairs and
you find you have a hard time doing that
because you're your quadricep your thigh
muscles are weak well a lot of that's
atrophy so if you do this program guess
what your body may not just tap into the
weight loss right off the bat it might
have to rebuild these proteins and that
is the point that you have to realize so
how do we enhance testosterone growth
hormone and insulin and glucagon let's
go through that well by doing healthy
Kido dropping your carbs having good
amount of fat moderate protein you can
stimulate testosterone growth hormone is
stimulated by small amounts of protein
or moderate amount of protein keeping
your blood Sugar's low sleep and intense
exercise so adding exercise is really
important I know you probably thought
that we want to keep insulin as close to
zero as possible but most people have
insulin resistance so they have a
situation where they have a lot of
insulin but it's ineffective it's not
working
so if it's not working you're gonna have
a hard time building muscle protein or
impairing body tissue that required me
know acids because you need this insulin
but as you do healthy keto and then
fasting you improve insulin resistance
so you start to have insulin now it's
available to you and it reduces but it's
more effective it actually works
as these hormones start to work better
and better you start having more effects
of these anabolic hormones so you have
more rebuilding so that tissues heal
they repair but maybe not weight loss
because you're gonna retain some of this
protein and it's a bit heavier if you
compare it to fat if you're looking at
the same volume but you will start
seeing waist size changes or reduction
pretty soon to stimulate glucagon you
have to increase protein and exercise
those are the two things with that so
don't forget to add exercise to your
healthy keto program definitely you can
work on intimate fasting start to go
less frequent if you want to speed
things up I talked about that even to
one meal a day and then number three
maybe you need to decrease your carbs a
little bit more maybe down to 10 grams
per meal and I have another program it's
called keto on steroids updated which
I'll be releasing shortly and it has
even a more hardcore program for those
people that are just like serious about
it and they just want to jump in and
just do whatever it takes
it's hardcore it's the ultimate deep
ketosis on steroids okay and then we may
recommend that you decrease your fat a
little bit because if you're doing these
MCT oil and too much coconut oil and and
you're doing bulletproof coffee all this
extra fat is unnecessary especially if
you're trying to burn your own fat why
give your body extra fat that has to
focus on that and leave your own fat
alone alright guys there you have it the
seven symptoms that prove that you are
in fat burning
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it